hable una señora Alex primero que todo
gracias por estar con nosotros de un
problema clave que atraviesa y marca la
existencia de las personas trans el no
reconocimiento de la identidad de género
que ocurre en muchos países
Hola buenos días un gusto estar con
ustedes pues sí efectivamente yo siempre
lo he dicho la mayor violencia que
sufrimos las personas trans es la no
identidad de género el no respeto a a
esta identidad que nos niegan a través
de leyes porque a través del no
reconocernos como personas trans
automáticamente se vuelve una
continuidad de violación a tu derecho
porque no tienes derecho a salud al
trabajo empleo a familia en fin desde
ahí se desencadena al no reconocimiento
de que estamos existimos y sobre todo
resistimos en resiliencia en esta
sociedad particularmente creo Usted que
hay una invisibilización de los varones
trans
Bueno si eso ha sido una cuestión que
que ha surgido históricamente creo que
los varones trans como fuimos somos
hijos del patriarcado también donde se
nos no se nos permitía cuestionar hablar
sino simple y sencillamente naturalizar
la violencia creo que esto nos hizo
estar en silencio durante muchísimos
años pero creo que hemos logrado ir
rompiendo poco a poco todo ese
patriarcado que hemos tenido encima y
hemos empezado a Elevar nuestras voces y
sobre todo hablar sobre nuestras propias
necesidades y las violencias que hemos
sufrido desde el momento que fuimos
asignados femeninos al nacer hay una
práctica de la que son víctimas las
personas trans y que horroriza las
denominadas violaciones correctivas
podría contarnos En qué consisten por
favor
Bueno quiero comentarte que en Guatemala
específicamente hicimos un estudio de
hombres trans donde el 80% de los
encuestados hablaron de haber sufrido
violaciones correctivas qué es lo que
sucede simple y sencillamente que como
fuiste asignado femenino al nacer tienes
que tener esa violencia sexual en tu
cuerpo para que realmente te des cuenta
que fuiste asignado femenino y por lo
tanto tienes que cumplir el rol de
procrear de engendrar de dar
fruto a la vida y eso es como muy común
y es donde los varones trans Muchas
veces tenemos que detener nuestra
transición porque obviamente
gestamos y al gestar pues vamos a tener
hijos hijas e hijas de quienes van a
depender económicamente de nosotros